The typical canine companion certainly gives his owner immeasurable happiness.
Not only that, but it's also obvious that the dog lives a life of remarkable leisure.
But some dogs happily perform very demanding jobs for much of their life,...
...putting in a full day's work just like the rest of us.
They are guide dogs, one of the most familiar sorts of working dog.
They provide an invaluable service to humans.
Every day, they help blind or visually impaired people get around more safely.
Furthermore, in most countries, they are allowed anywhere that the public is allowed,...
...so they can help their masters be any place they might want to go.
To do this, a guide dog must know how to:...
...keep on a direct route,...
...ignoring distractions such as smells, other animals and people.
Maintain a steady pace, to the left and just ahead of the master.
Stop at all curbs until told to proceed.
Turn left and right, move forward and stop on command.
Recognize and avoid obstacles that the master won't be able to fit through.
Stop at the bottom and top of stairs until told to proceed.
Bring the master to elevator buttons.
Lie quietly when the master is sitting down.
Help the master to board and move around buses, subways and other forms of public transportation.
Obey a number of verbal commands.